we all know las vegas is the
entertainment capital of the world and
this weekend is no exception thanks for
joining us tonight at six i'm sasha
loftis we have a jam-packed lineup that
includes a long-awaited boxing match and
a 60th anniversary tribute to a
legendary band madison kimbrough joins
us from the strip with all the details
there are events happening all over las
vegas and several people we spoke to
came into town just to attend we'll
start with the boxing match between
pacquiao and ugas happening at t-mobile
arena tonight doors opened at 4 and the
fight will take place at 6 p.m now into
pop music the jonas brothers are
performing at park theater at park mgm
for their remember this tour that starts
at 7 p.m tonight marshmallow and other
electronic djs are also set to perform
on the strips
and if you are a world wrestling
entertainment fan summerslam 2021 is
taking place at allegiant stadium roman
reigns defends his universal
championship in the main event against
john cena who's returned to the ring
doors opened at 4 30. we caught up with
some people here on the strip to hear
who they are most excited about seeing
we're expecting like
some so many fans
screaming around
everybody excited because this tour is
we are it's been amazing we have um
a great expectations for the show
and we hope we have so much fun tonight
got
marshmallow tonight who's one of my
favorite artists you got you know it's
vegas you have to experience it at least
once and happening downtown a 60th
anniversary celebration of the beatles
it's an all you need is love tribute
honoring them and other world's greatest
rock bands that starts at 7 p.m on abbey
road crossing on fremont street also dj
artist kygo will be at xs tonight at
wynn and millennium will perform at
omnia nightclub that's going to be at
caesar's palace reporting on the las
vegas strip madison kimbrough 8 news now